the media likes to sensationalize this
as if you have some Eureka moment or you
are some singular person who can't build
something on your own and that's just
not how the world works look at your day
yesterday are you gonna tell me that was
your best day that you gave it the best
that you had no Amazon started as a very
small company it was me and a few other
people I was driving all the packages to
the post office myself in my 1987 Chevy
Blazer
rise and shine it's expresso time what's
up belief nation itself in my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded on to
the world so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message keep on going over to
you Mark Zuckerberg
[Music]
it wasn't so long ago that you know I
was a student and you know sitting in in
a seat in an auditorium like you guys
are here today listening to I remember
very specifically this time when Bill
Gates came to talk ed at Harvard and I'm
like wow how do you how do you do that
you know the trick is is that the media
likes to sensationalize this as if you
have some Eureka moment or you are some
singular person who I can't build
something on your own and that's just
not how the world works when I was in
school I built a lot of stuff that I
just like building there was not a
single moment when I when I had some
revelation that Facebook was going to be
awesome
that's not maybe how the media or movies
or whatever would like to portray things
it's not it's much less exciting but the
reality is I think most I services in
the world that reach the scale that
Facebook has you start off building
something that you care about and you
know you don't necessarily think it's
gonna be that big I didn't you know I
built Facebook the first version of
Facebook for my college community
because I wanted to be able to connect
to the people at my school and I
remember very clearly talking to my
friends at the time and saying you know
it's how cool is it that we have built
this community for our school you know
one day it's gonna be awesome when
somebody else builds this for the world
because something like this needs to
exist for the world but it didn't even
occur to me that you know my friends and
I might be able to play a role in doing
that or because we were college students
right I mean we didn't have any you know
engineers to work with or servers or
resources or anything like that and you
know there were these huge companies
that deliver products for hundreds of
millions of people right there's I
always assumed that it was gonna be like
Microsoft or Google or someone would
build this for the world and what
basically just happened is at each step
along the way we just kind of kept doing
the next thing and
growing from there and you know there
were teams inside these other companies
that that thought social media was
important and we're working on it but
there were all these different memes and
narratives in the world you know people
would say oh well you know this is just
a fad people are gonna use it but then
they're gonna stop so you know so a lot
of the teams who were working on didn't
take it that seriously or you know the
higher-ups and those companies didn't
care so then get resources and we just
kept going and going and then people
would say alright well alright fine so
maybe people are using it but it's never
gonna make any money all right I mean
social media doesn't make any money yeah
we just kind of kept going and going and
then pretty soon we had a service that
was bigger than any of these other ones
and that kind of is how we are here
where we are there's no magic you know a
lot of times I think people just get
afraid because you know often your dream
is its it seems like it's so so far off
but but if you just kind of focus on
building stuff that you think is good
and and you keep on going at each step
along the way and don't let people deter
you from that and you just really care
about what you're doing and kind of
don't give up but each step along the
way then you know I think that's how you
that's how you build something good to
be a successful entrepreneur you need to
have patience and impatience people just
have it in the wrong areas most people
are impatient with the results but
they're patient with themselves they are
impatient with the results but they're
patient with themselves what that means
you're impatient with the results you
want results you want it to happen now
you've been putting in the work where is
the results why is your channel not
growing why is your business not growing
why are you not getting more customers
more word-of-mouth more moments and why
isn't that happening
doesn't happen I've been putting in time
it's been a week it's been three months
it's been a year where is the results
the massive sense of impatience around
the results that's where most people are
and yet you're patient with yourself you
don't put in your best every day you
know that today could have gone better
you know you could have brought more to
today look at your day yesterday are you
gonna tell me that was your best day
that you gave it the best that you had
not that it's the best in the world but
the best that you have did you give your
best yesterday did you give your best
day before did you give your best at any
point and any time this year at all did
you ever give your best no you're too
patient with yourself you're impatient
about the results but you're patient
with yourself you let yourself slide you
let yourself think well tomorrow I'll
have a better day or the next week I'll
have a better day or when I get my new
system I'll have a better day when I get
my new camera I have a better day when
the government passes new legislation
I'll have a better day your better day
is always coming you're too patient with
yourself we're what I want you to do is
flipp'n what you need to be is impatient
with yourself and patient with the
results in patient with yourself and
patient with the results what I mean by
that is be patient with the work that
you're doing on a daily basis to know
that you could do better be impatient
around that I want this video to be the
best video that I've ever made period up
until this point I want it to be good I
want to be great I wanted to be better
I'm hard on myself daily I'm extremely
impatient that today is not going as
well as I could and yesterday could have
gone better I am insanely sickly
impatient about that I want to bring my
best every single possible day but I'm
patient with the results I know that if
I bring my best and I get better every
single day I may not be the best in the
world but if I bring my best every day
that I will get better and the results
will come that the results will come
maybe it's in a year maybe it's
three years maybe is five years maybe
it's ten years but the results will come
and I want you to flip that stop being
so patient with yourself and impatient
with the results flip it be impatient
with yourself and be more patient with
the results when you get there that's
when you're going to flip the switch
that's when you start getting more
success that's when you stop complaining
that's when you're stopped coasting
that's we're gonna start to see results
for your business for the life that you
want for the community that you want to
build for the impact that you want to
have patience and impatience both
massively valuable you just have to know
how to use them now I've got some very
special bonus stuff to you but before
that question today I want to know what
are you impatient in leave it down the
comments below super curious to find out
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso and
enjoy the bonus clips
[Music]
so your question is you know did I kind
of anticipate what would happen over the
last 22 years and Amazon and the answer
is god no so you know Amazon started as
a very small company it was me and a few
other people I was driving all the
packages to the post office myself in my
1987 Chevy Blazer and when I raised
money for Amazon I had to raise a
million dollars which I raised from 22
different investors $50,000 each
they got 20% of the company for for the
million dollars and it was a 40 people
told me no so I did take 60 meetings to
get 20 yeses the first question was
always what's the internet and I had to
walk through that and this was 1994
early 95 and so did I anticipate you
know fast forward to today and and the
current version of it no it has been one
foot in front of the other and I think
that that is true for most businesses
where you kind of proceed adaptively its
step by step you figure it out you have
a success and then you kind of double
down on that success and you figure out
what what else you can do what customers
want it's always success in failure you
just have to know where to look for it
and that means that's a learning moment
so you say AV Vega is success in
learning if you know how to know exactly
you just have to look for it because
then you use that again and you make
sure you don't make that mistake again
or don't allow that mistake to have it
so your goal is to then just because it
didn't work out the way you wanted to
take that knowledge take those learnings
and reapply it to a new you know a new
direction and therefore you're gonna get
better no one's you know I've had I've
had failure and it takes years of
building up that kind of thick skin
around you but that's what it means to
be resilient you just get up and you
keep going and you can and I can't tell
you there's been times when I just sat
there I was like oh the world's gonna be
over and then you know what you just
look at it and you think about it and
you have to project yourself not to
but to project yourself into the future
what could I do in the future if you
keep looking ahead everybody fails
you're not the only one
everybody does just get over it keep
going raise your standard Apple at the
core its core value is that we believe
that people with passion and not one
drop of my self-worth depends on your
acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details